ring ring ring ring ring ring ring
banana phone
classic we'd like to have fun over here
at SCP explained and that's why today
we'll be talking about one of the most
sweet and playful anomalies that the
foundation has in containment if by
sweet we mean it smells like overripe
fruit and by playful we mean carnivorous
and genetically unstable then yes that's
exactly what's in store for us meet
scp-2761 a mutant hybrid we've
affectionately nicknamed banana Zilla
due to the scp's retractable frill which
resembles the peel of a banana tree
fruit though at first glance this part
of
scp-2761's anomalous Anatomy might
appear fanciful like something out of a
cartoon or children's picture book
bananazilla is no laughing matter and it
boasts far fewer novel surprises across
the length of its 12 meter body the fact
is
scp-2761 could prove an existential
threat to every natural ecosystem on
Earth if it were ever to Escape
containment the reason for this happens
to be
scp-2761's infinitely adaptable genetic
code which seems to constantly evolve in
response to its consumption of other
organisms at present
scp-2761 is amphibious and can Thrive as
easily in salt water as it does in the
fresh water of its containment unit at
site 71. while it does possess skills
they are extremely small similar in
proportion to those found on species in
the pipefish subfamily the foundation's
research into the creature's origin has
led to the prevailing theory that it may
have begun its life as an ordinary
pipefish and was subject to DNA splicing
at a retail company known as aquagene
which specializes in the sale of
genetically modified aquatic paths
regardless of its origin
scp-2761 shares genotypic and phenotypic
traits with over five dozen species of
Flora and Fauna aside from pipefish the
majority of these species belong to the
animal Kingdom and overwhelmingly tend
to belong to the amphibian rayfin fish
or reptile classes these borrowed genes
Express themselves in a variety of ways
but always in a manner that seems
beneficial to
scp-2761 Banana zilla's gigantic body is
capable of explosive bursts at speed
much like soft-shelled turtles which
over the course of their Natural
Evolution sacrificed more protective
armor to gain greater Mobility for the
purposes of detecting prey bananazilla
has 16 barbells more commonly referred
to as catfish whiskers which like its
frill are fully retractable in terms of
physical appearance
scp-2761 has many traits in common with
American alligators this includes the
over 100 undifferentiated conical teeth
which
scp-2761 can use to devour live prey
there are nearly 60 additional rows of
teeth with an
scp-2761's mouth which on the off chance
that the hybrid loses any teeth in the
front row will naturally move forward to
replace them the process by which
scp-2761 regenerates lost teeth is
nearly identical to that of a bull shark
however the replacement teeth vary in
shape and apparent utility some rows of
banana zilla's backup teeth are
uniformly serrated and evenly spaced
while other rows are villiform with
prominent elongated canines like that of
a yellowtail snapper fish a dental
examination of
scp-2761 revealed that towards the back
of its mouth there were even rows of
teeth that bore an uncanny resemblance
to those found within a species of great
ape the human species to be exact the
alligator-like claws at the end of
scp-2761's powerful compact limbs have
sticky pads on the underside which have
enough adhesive strength to allow
scp-2761 to climb into trees and across
other uneven surfaces such as the
artificial Rock we've provided banana
Zilla in its containment unit for the
purpose of exercise and stimulation
these adhesive pads are identical to the
ones found on the toes of green and oily
lizards which
scp-2761 appears to have inherited other
characteristics from such as the ability
to perceive ultraviolet light and
limited color changing for the purpose
of camouflage when
scp-2761 was first discovered deep in
the heart of the Florida Everglades the
range of its color changing ability
comprise several shades of green and
brown from a vibrant lustrous green like
that of an emerald gemstone to a dark
muddy Hue that made it nearly invisible
in murky water it is believed that the
consistent diet of banana fruit that the
foundation provides to
scp-2761 has been able to gradually
offset its camouflage capabilities
inadvertently causing it to retain the
natural coloration of bright yellow that
it has become known for the secret to
scp-2761's vast amount of genetic
information lies in its cellular
structure each cell in SCP 2761's bulky
body has an abnormally large nucleus
with a primary genome makeup of hundreds
of distinct genes there are additional
genomes stored separately within the
nuclei as well which have been heavily
scrutinized by research Personnel of
level 3 and above all available data
seems to suggest that
scp-2761's full genetic code contains
the completely unaltered genomes of
every species it has ever eaten this
includes a diverse microbiome of
bacteria and organic compounds which
would be hazardous to most other
creatures but seem to only affect the
hybrid carnivore's Health in terms of
conferring benefits though the various
diseases and genetic disorders that
scp-2761 Harbors within its body present
no safety risk to the SCP itself any
bloodborne or contagious strains of
microscopic life are still more than
capable of having their usual adverse
effects on other species to prevent the
spread of these harmful pathogens the
foundation has lined the containment
unit for scp-20 761 with lead as the
heavy metal is known to induce
antimicrobial activity despite the
tendency for
scp-2761 to undergo rapid mutation
within its primary genome the numerous
unaltered genomes within its cells have
never shown signs of independent
mutation instead these unaltered genomes
serve as a function that is
metaphorically comparable to the extra
rows of teeth within
scp-2761's mouth whenever the primary
genome suffers damage or makes contact
with potentially hazardous new stimuli
genetic information is transferred from
the unaltered genomes to repair
scp-2761's genetic expression and in the
process cause further beneficial
mutations to take place in short
scp-2761 is capable of storing
unexpressed genetic data within its
cells which then becomes apparent in its
physical characteristics provided that
those changes make it fitter to survive
in its current environment the untapped
potential of this advanced form of
genetic rearrangement has become
increasingly enticing to the foundation
not unlike the enticing Taste of a fresh
delicious banana as the saying goes
scp-2761 is what it eats therefore it
stands to reason that altering the
hybrid's food intake could over time
lead to a genetic expression that would
there improve useful to the foundation's
goals this is especially true when the
mutable properties of
scp-2761 are compared to those of a
similar but far more dangerous reptilian
SCP the infamous
scp-682 while scp-682 is nearly
impossible to destroy due to its
instantaneous adaptation the changes to
its physiology recede and disappear when
no longer required to ensure its
Survival
scp-2761 on the other hand retains the
sum total of every useful feature it has
gleaned from its diet presently
scp-2761 possesses barely a fraction of
scp-682's overall strength and
destructive capability but if raised
properly within a long enough time frame
with a steady and balanced diet of the
optimal anomalous and non-anomalous
organisms it is theorized that
scp-2761 could be molded into the ideal
countermeasure for its reptilian rival
and most crucially to the plan because
banana Zilla hunts only out of
carnivorous Instinct for sustenance and
survival it lacks any of the malice
towards other life which defines the
Twisted joker-like psychology of the
hard to destroy reptile if this
desirable outcome Were Somehow to be
achieved the final containment of
scp-682 would be all but assured even if
its total impermanent destruction remain
forever out of the foundation's reach
for now even the notion of broadening
scp-2761's diet has been deemed to be
far too risky to attempt even a
mouth-watering jumbo-sized bucket of
seemingly harmless non-specific
restaurant brand chicken wings could
cause the hybrid to develop razor-sharp
Talons a highly disturbing morning call
or an unforeseen boost in intelligence
that might Aid in its escaping
containment not to mention the possible
spread of Avian Influenza though the
finer details regarding banana zilla's
genetics are known only to sufficiently
high-ranking members of the genetic
research team rumors have circulated
throughout site-71 that this humble SCP
may still prove to be an incredible
asset in another way if the highly
adaptable cells within its body can
somehow be replicated this has recently
been the obsession of one Dr scapelli
Who as an Avid Reader of comic books and
manga has hypothesized or more
accurately fantasized that the human
genome could be augmented through the
integration of transplanted cells from
scp-2761 in scapelli's eyes which by all
estimates are filled with a naive
optimism generally unexpected in a level
3 researcher a successful transplant
could turn a regular human being into a
highly adaptable mutant super being able
to become stronger with every meal
admits the persistent worry of his
scientific peers Dr scapelli has in his
off-duty hours drafted unofficial plans
for what he believes could be the
greatest mobile task force the
foundation has ever known these heroic
Warriors would be given the designation
mobile task force Tau 68 but all the
villains in the world would know and
fear them by their clever and ingenious
code name The Banana Splits while every
recipient of a successful banana Zilla
cell transplant would be allowed into
the group a core team of Specialists
would be chosen to embody Dr scapelli's
wildly imaginative and yet incredibly
specific tastes standing at the top of
the food chain would be the task Force's
chief commander Apex man with an
all-meat diet consisting of mostly
deadly predators from around the globe
Apex man would bear the responsibilities
of leadership Badger the bad guys wolf
down all snakes in the grass and
Crocodile Rock the world into
Everlasting peace with his egalitarian
ways and he's not not lion okay we'll
stop for now
[Laughter]
oh fun Apex man's loyal second in
command would be honeygirl empowered by
the environmental DNA of thousands of
pollinated plants and the bees that tend
to them this graceful soldier of Justice
would have the foundation's enemies
sneezing from Mercy with her countless
allergenic attacks flower power indeed
next of course would be the lord of the
sea a pescetarian who's always part
shellfish but never a bit selfish when
it comes to saving the day his powerful
retractable tentacles would squeeze the
fight out of even the most wicked
villain and with shark-like teeth of his
own he never failed to take a bite out
of anomalous crime watching over the
team from the skies is wild turkey
gobbling up important reconnaissance
data as quickly as he gobbles up his
favorite poultry dishes this bad Birdman
is here to give evildoers a foul time
last but not least would be the teen
tofu Titan himself the cube 100 boy 100
soy yeah I know doctors Capelli's
eventual proposal for mobile task force
Tau 68 was met with uproarious laughter
and was unanimously turned down by every
level three and higher Personnel who was
present to hear it 05-1 actually gave
him 10 bucks afterwards as thanks for
giving him such a good giggle Dr
scapelli was not pleased disgraced and
humiliated Dr scafelli chose to take a
lengthy sabbatical from site 71 but as
he packed up his notes for mobile task
force Tau 68 which included several
pencil and paper illustrations he had
done by hand the researcher was overcome
with a sense of righteous purpose The
Banana Splits were an idea so brilliant
that he couldn't just give up on them if
the foundation wouldn't help Dr scapelli
realize his dream he had an idea who
would on the night before he departed
from site-71 scapelli used his authority
as a member of level 3 Personnel to
access the research lab and secure a DNA
sample from scp-2761
he proceeded to erase any and all
records of him having entered the lab
that night without any further delay Dr
scapelli booked a non-stop flight to the
Sunshine State of Florida he had one
destination in mind the Orlando regional
headquarters of aquagene surely the
company responsible for accidentally
creating banana Zilla would understand
the importance of using their genetic
research for the betterment of the world
yes of course they would understand
scapelli thought to himself as he fell
asleep on the plane while he napped Dr
scapelli dreamed of the Glorious Day
that his secret mobile task force would
save the world and prove everyone who
ever doubted him to be totally in the
wrong in the dream several dangerous
scps had escaped containment including
scp-058 the Heart of Darkness this
cutter-class monstrosity was on a brutal
Rampage throughout its containment
facility lashing out with its horrifying
tendrils at any Personnel Within Reach
just when all hope seemed lost Dr
scapelli would arrive with mobile task
force Tau 68 in
of the coolest and strongest members of
the super team were standing at his side
ready for action Apex man honey girl the
lord of the sea wild turkey and the cube
Banana Splits assemble Dr scapelli's
Dream self shouted his genetically
modified Heroes proceeded to bring the
ultimate Smackdown to scp-058 from the
palms of her hands honeygirl Unleashed
viscous Globs of her namesake substance
which stuck the heart of darkness's
arthropod legs to the floor holding it
in place as expected the heart began to
launch into one of its unnerving
speeches thought to drive listeners to
Madness the wild turkey made gobbling
noises at the top of his lungs to drown
out the sound trapped and effectively
silenced but not defeated
scp-058's thrashing tentacles were still
a major problem until the lord of the
sea extended his own tentacles to match
the monster blow for blow finally Apex
man's grizzly bear DNA could no longer
resist the honey-covered heart in front
of him and he closed in on scp-0582
crush it with the granddaddy of bear
hugs before scarfing it down with a
noisy crunch the Heart of Darkness was
beaten and eaten in that order the other
researchers cheered and clapped for Dr
scapelli and for his Banana Splits
overcome with unconditional praise the
likes of which Dr scapelli had never
experienced everyone around him began to
chant his name
compad dream version of Apex man
approached Dr scapelli and gave his
creator a congratulatory pattern on the
back those who hide unwanted things in
the fog must eternally reckon with the
afterimage of his Twilight sinful
longing said Apex man in the vocal tone
and accent of an elderly British man he
proceeded to sprout four tentacles
similar to those of scp-058 Dr scapelli
jolted awake with a scream only to see
that he was the last one still aboard
his plane an irritated flight attendant
told the researcher that his flight had
touched down at Orlando International
Airport and that he needed to grab his
carry-on luggage and exit the aircraft
immediately scapelli didn't need to be
told twice he made a beeline out of the
airport and called a cab to take him to
the resort he had booked for his stay
after settling into a hotel room the
researcher made a few phone calls and
before long he was able to secure an
impromptu meeting with two of the
scientists in aquagine's employee Dr
Pearl Watkins and Dr Marcus Nakamura
both Watkins and nakam Mora had been
previously contacted by Foundation
researcher Matthew Leo under the guise
of meeting with the EPA the foundation
had been keeping tabs on them since then
while maintaining their cover while the
scientists had assisted in the
successful containment of
scp-2761 the potential of Aqua Gene's
genetic technology needed to be
monitored in the event of further
anomalous creation it wasn't difficult
for Dr scapelli to insert himself into
the narrative that aquagene already
believed posing as another agent of the
EPA looking to inspect the company's
policies of course since he was
operating without the permission of the
foundation Dr scapelli made sure that
the meeting was held at aquagene
headquarters Watkins and Nakamura were
apprehensive enough given the scrutiny
that researcher Leo had put them under
in their first meeting and became
increasingly alarmed as Dr scapelli
presented them with the scp-2761 sample
as well as his creative pitch it would
be a superhero group like in the movies
Dr scapelli exclaimed had being just
spoken at length about the viability of
mobile task force Tau 68. the aquagene
employees exchanged terror-stricken
looks Nakamura was the first to speak it
is a tempting offer Marcus began trying
to be polite but our budget is stretched
thin enough as it is your project he
jumped with shock as Dr scapelli cut him
off mid-sentence don't worry about the
funding I I can cover it out of pocket
sure I might have to take out a loan and
possibly apply for unemployment but
isn't saving the world worth any price
Watkins reported we try to do things
very carefully here agents Capelli I'll
be blunt what you're describing is far
beyond the scope of our research and
using live Human test subjects for this
seems highly unethical unethical Dr
scapelli said baffled what could
possibly be unethical about using people
to fight evil I think what Pearl is
trying to say is Nakamura chimed in this
all seems a bit naive Dr scapelli sunk
into his chair feeling defeated first
the foundation had rejected his idea and
now aquagine too perhaps it really was
time to to give up on mobile Task Force
Town 68. if he pressed his luck any
further at Aqua Gene Ward could get back
to site-71 and he'd have to kiss his
career at the foundation goodbye and
potentially his memories if they decided
to give him a hefty dose of amnestics as
part of his severance package later that
night in the Resort Restaurant Dr
scapelli was crawling into his plate of
food his dreams of creating the world's
first superhero team had been crushed
that day and he still had the rest of
his sabbatical to spend in Florida as he
tried to eat a steak he was reminded of
Apex man and broke down in tears all
over again the other restaurant patrons
were beginning to stare at Dr scapelli
and he was about to consider leaving
when a man in Dark Shades approached his
table and sat down across from him the
man waited for scapelli disease his
weeping before formally introducing
himself as Dr Gregory Higgins he claimed
to be a former employee at aquagine and
had used Insider information from an old
colleague to learn about Dr scapelli's
meeting with Watkins and Nakamura by
tracing the call from the resort earlier
that that afternoon it wasn't that
difficult to track the foundation
researcher down are you gonna call me
naive too scapelli said far from it
Higgins replied wearing a mischievous
grin I think your idea has potential you
really mean it skipelly's face lit up
Higgins laugh of course but then again
what do I know I'm just the guy who
created that banana Zilla he continued
it was a complete accident of course but
I think we could really make Pearl and
Marcus regret ever doubting us if this
superhero thing goes the way you think
it will Dr scapelli smiled Higgins this
is the beginning of a beautiful
partnership the two genetic scientists
one formerly of the foundation and the
other formerly of aquagine laughed and
shared Joy at the things they might soon
accomplish there were only two words to
describe the chaos that might ensue from
the combined imagination of this couple
of mad Geniuses totally bananas now go
check out scp-682 ways as CP Foundation
try to kill the hard to destroy reptile
and
scp-6415 tragedy of the reptile man for
more fascinating reptilian anomalies